oculus VR have found themselves in a  tight spot this weekend as they're  facing yet another lawsuit this time for  breach of contract and fraud related  offenses as reported by Reuters the  lawsuit in question comes from Total  Recall technologies who are accusing  rift creator Parma lucky of quote taking  confidential information he learned  while working with another company and  passing it off as his own Total Recall  say that lucky was hired in 2011 to  create a prototype vr headset and  subsequently received feedback and  information to improve on that prototype  they're claiming the lucky then used  that information to launch his  Kickstarter for the oculus rift ignoring  the confidentiality agreement that he  sign Total Recall are after compensatory  and punitive damages but the dollar  amount hasn't been released publicly let  me know down in the comments who you  think is in the right for guarding this  one and we'll keep you posted with any  and all updates on gamespot